let's say that we're looking to borrow
$50 so we can say that our principal is
$50 we're going to borrow it for three
years so our time let's say T in years
is three and let's say we're not going
to just compound per year we're going to
compound we're going to compound four
times a year or every three months and
let's say that our interest rate let's
say that our interest rate if we were to
if we would if we were only compound
once per year it would be 10% but since
we're going to compound four times year
we're going to see in an expression
we're going to divide this by four to
see how much we compound each period so
10% is the same thing zero point one
zero so let's write an expression I
encourage you actually to pause this
video and try to write an expression for
the amount of the amount that you would
have to pay back if you were to if you
were to do this if you were to borrow
$50 over three years compounding four
times a year each period you would be
compounding 10% divided by 4% how much
would you have to pay back in three
years let's write it out 50 dollars
that's your principal and you're going
to multiply that you're going to
multiply that so you're going to cut our
so you could compound it each time each
period each of these three times four
periods you have three years each of
them have each of them divided into four
sections you're gonna have twelve
periods so each of them you're going to
compound by one plus your this are so
I'll write that as a decimal
0.10 divided by the number of times
you're compounding per year to the to
the well you'd be raising it to the nth
power if this was only over a year so
you there's four periods and you'd raise
it to the fourth power if it was only a
year but this is three years so you're
going to be doing this three times for
three you're going to do you're going to
you're going to have four periods three
times so let me write this so it's going
to be four four actually let me write
instead of n right over here let me
write the four so you see all the
numbers so you're going to do this four
times 3 to the 4 times 3 power and we
could even you call hide encourage you
if you want you could pause the video
and you can use your
calculator to actually calculate what
that is but the whole point of this is
just to use real numbers to see why this
actually makes sense this is your
principal each time you're going to be
multiplying that times one point one
point zero to five where you're going to
be compound you're going to be you're
going to be growing it by two and a half
percent and you're going to do this 12
times because there's there's 12 periods
four periods per year times three years
so this is going to be how much you have
to pay back so if we wanted to write
this a little bit more abstract terms we
could write this as P times one plus and
I'll do the close parentheses since it's
the same color are over over N to the N
times T n times T power and so you could
pick your P your T's your ends your and
your R and you could put it here and
that's essentially how much you're going
to have to pay back now an interesting
thing and you saw that we had this up
here from a previous video where we took
the limit as n approaches infinity well
let's do the same thing here let's think
about what that would mean if we took
the limit as n approaches infinity if we
took the limit of this as n approaches
infinity what are we what is what is
this conceptually well we're dividing
our we're dividing our year into into
more and more and more chunks an
infinite number of chunks so you could
really say well this would be the case
where we're doing continuous compound
interest which is a fascinating concept
to me you are just you're dividing
you're dividing your time period in an
infinite number of chunks and then and
then compounding just an infinitely
small extra amount every one of those
periods but you can actually come up
with an expression for that and as we
see that this actually doesn't just go
unbounded and give us crazy things that
we can actually use this to come up with
a formula for continuously compounding
interest which is use heavily in finance
and well and banking and then as you
convention a bunch of things and
actually things many many things outside
of finance and banking exponential
growth etc etc so let's see if we can
actually try to evaluate this thing
right over here
well the one thing I am going to do to
simplify this is to do a substitution so
I'm going to define a variable I'm going
to define the whole goal is so I can get
it into a form that looks something like
this I'm going to define a variable X X
and I'm going to say that X is the
reciprocal of R over N so that I can get
a 1 over X right over here so I'll write
that as n over R X is equal to n over n
over R or we could write this as n N is
equal to x times R n is equal to X times
X times R and if we make that
substitution the limit as n approaches
infinity well if we take the limit as X
approaches infinity then n is going to
go to infinity as well or if n goes to
infinity then X is going to go to
infinity as well all right over here is
just a constant term we're just assuming
that that's a given that n is what we're
really we're really seeing what happens
as we change it so we could rewrite this
thing right over here and I'm doing it
I'm not being as super rigorous but it's
really to give you an intuition for
where the formula we're about to see
comes from let's rewrite this as the
limit as X approaches infinity the limit
as X approaches infinity and the limit
of some constant times some expression
well we could take the constant out so
we could say that's going to be P times
the limit as X approaches infinity of 1
plus well R over N is 1 over X 1 plus 1
over X 1 over X to the to the well n is
x times R and is x times R so let me
write that to the x times our R times T
power T power well they all of this
business is the exact same thing so let
me rewrite this let me let me copy and
paste this part right over here so copy
this is the same thing this is equal to
P times and we put some parentheses here
times maybe that's too big
time's the limit so this limit right
over here so if I raise something to the
product of these I'm taking X times R
times T well that's the same thing as
doing this whole thing to the X and then
raising that to the RT power R T power
this comes from this comes from exponent
properties that you might have learned
before these two things are equivalent
I'm and I'm doing a couple of steps in
the process here but hopefully this
makes this seems really reasonably
intuitive intuitive for you I'm really
just using the property that the limit
the limit as let's say X approaches C of
f of X of f of X to the let's call it to
the X R XR t power this is the same
thing as the limit as X approaches C of
f of X to the X and then all of that
raised to the RT power well what is this
stuff right over here what is all of
this business that's inside the
parentheses well we've seen that before
all of this all of that is equal to e so
we can write this and this is exciting
this is this is a formula for continuous
compounding interest that if we
continuously compound we're going to
have to pay back our principal times e
times e to the RT power to the R T RT
power so let's do a concrete example
here if you were to borrow if you were
to borrow 50 dollars over three years
10% interest but you're not you're not
compounding just four times a year
you're going to compound an infinite
times per year you're going to be
continuous compounding so we can see how
much you would actually have to pay back
it is going to be it is going to be 50
times e to the our rate is 0.1 so let me
put some parentheses here 0.1 times time
so times 3 years T is
years we assumed it was in years and we
get you would have to pay back $67 and
if we were to round 1460 $7.49 if you
were to round